hello and welcome to episode
163 of Gamespot after dark I am your
host amore saying joined as always bye
Jake Decker we got a new table we got a
new table
John Luke tell us about the Odyssey that
left that you went through to get this
table well it's it's not a new table
it's a new old table yeah this is this
is people who watch giant Bombay
recognize us as the old giant bomb table
that was in their Studio back on the
first floor yeah
um it was abandoned it was left next to
CNET and Cena said we don't want this
and I said I want that so that's history
baby we need that yeah we also have the
old jamb on couch which is we're just
slowly morphing into Giant Bomb you've
got two giant bomb employees yeah and
stuff so you know we're just slowly
becoming Giant Bomb we're also joined by
Stuart hey this isn't your first
appearance so you don't need to be
babied anymore so please quiet down
sorry
appreciate it uh let's kick off with
what we've been playing Stuart can you
pipe up about what you've been playing
yes I I can pipe up about what I've been
playing uh I got to preview uh Mario
Rabbids uh Sparks of hope the new one uh
yeah you just have let us play about
three hours of it at an event and I I
really enjoyed my time with it I was uh
I think the biggest thing about it is
movement is actually fun in a tactical
game which usually is not the case
um and they actually use the movement in
the combat uh and integrate those
extremely well like Mario has this move
where he can like jump on top of an
enemy and then like Neo style double gun
shoot people in the air which is pretty
safe is the world ready for that to see
Mario do we've already seen Mario's
nipples so probably yeah yeah that's
true yeah yeah but I yeah I had a great
time with it uh levels were well
designed and all that good stuff uh we
have a preview out I believe on Gamespot
we do went up earlier today so yeah it's
good stuff when you say movement was fun
right what do you mean by that and how
is it different from the last game
because if I remember the last game it
was like you'd move around and then
occasionally stuff yourself in a pipe
and teleport around right so what makes
it different now and how what makes the
movement fun now as opposed to what it
was previously they um they got rid of
the grid entirely so it's like a free
movement Zone you have you know your
character has a set
space that they can inhabit but uh it's
not like grid based anymore uh and you
can do things like you can go into the
pipes and stuff and do the team jump
abilities but now you have like dashes
and different things and there's one uh
character that you can actually uh power
up that she can do three dashes at a
time that like electrocute enemies so
it's all worked into the uh to the
combat and the traversal of like each
stage
um and they sell the pipes and stuff
okay but it just feels more fluid and
more like instead of just like here's
the turn here's the enemy's turn here's
our turn and like it feels less plotting
than than I remember the first one being
right do different characters have
different movement ranges like does
peach have a wider area for example than
Mario or something exactly like Luigi is
kind of like the the sniper class he has
like this bow that he can use which is
pretty awesome and uh
he definitely has a limited uh movement
range but like Mario and the Mario
rabbit are kind of like the brawler
class and he just like the Peach has
like a shotgun umbrella it was great
um the Penguin from Batman yes exactly
um and so like they have a wider area
that they can cover because they're
supposed to be up close and personal and
right and taking shots like that okay
cool what are the new characters do they
show any of those offs uh I think well
they showed Rayman and that was they
made a big deal out of ready man
yeah
I thought it was going to be Wario like
I was like It's gotta be Wario Waluigi
one of them and then it cut to Rhema I
was like who cares who literally cares
like about Rayman being in this game
like Rayman needs to be in the cool like
sad scrolling platformer creative game
they put him in and I was like because
they were like we're so uh happy that we
were trusted with this character and
then it cut to Rayman I was like you
guys you you need to take it down I'm
not sure what you're how you hide you
guys know that character yeah yeah
you got crazy man
funny yeah no so we didn't get to play
as Bowser if it was another one
announced but we did get to uh I did get
to play as uh rabid Rosalina which is
cool because like the and the other
thing about the game is that the
um the Sparks themselves are a
combination of Rabbids and Lumas okay
and you can uh now apply Sparks to your
character to add like the electric uh
electrifying Dash thing is a spark okay
um and you can use those as like AOE
effects or
um like on your character themselves
yeah right so yeah uh rabbit Rosalina
was fun I didn't get too much time with
the the new character because it was one
boss battle right and it was she wasn't
fully like upgraded or anything so
um
yeah that was that was my time with uh
what's the who's what's the bad guy in
this one uh antagonist cursor who I
didn't really get uh a good glimpse of
but I did have a battle I don't even
remember the story from the first game I
just remember playing it and being like
I don't care about any of this I just
want to do tactical combat stuff and if
you like that yeah it's it's really good
yeah I had a lot of fun with that
interesting I heard the music is really
good oh yeah the three I mean you got
Grant Kirk hope and then I I'm
forgetting the other two is David Weiss
no no someone else let me have a look
yeah three composers and they do an
amazing job and I will say you know
rabid Rosalina came on and like the the
theme from the The Hub area of my Galaxy
played and I was like all right that
hits oh my God it's yokoshimamura who
um who's like Street Fighter uh oh wow
fantasy like Yoko shimamura is like one
of the most acclaimed musicians in like
Xenoblade I'm reading I'll read some of
the games okay xana blade Mario and
Luigi Kingdom Hearts uh Mario Rabbids
more Kingdom Hearts a half minute hero
um yeah it's three five two
uh yeah a little final fight nice a lot
of good Breath of Fire
Super Mario RPG all kinds of stuff and
then Gareth Cocker
who's also very very acclaimed uh
oriented blind Forest Story and the will
of the Wisps uh and then daughter and a
few others as well
um yeah that's well there you go that's
that's the three so the soundtrack was
awesome yeah absolutely lovely
um that sounds like fun yeah I'm excited
to check that out it was a good time
um what else have you been checking out
playing uh playing I've been playing a
lot of Halo because that's the video I'm
doing this week going back to Halo 3
which I haven't played in a very long
time but is still just as fun as ever
um it's got more content than Halo
infinite so why not yeah there you go
um what else have been playing not a lot
of new stuff just because of the videos
I've been doing how is how does Halo 3
hold up oh it's I mean it's awesome it's
better than I remember it to be honest
same with Assassin's Creed when I was
playing that I was like oh damn these
game 15 year old games now are like
still design wise just tight like
playing through some of the campaign
levels of Halo 3 I was like oh I get why
or why this was such a big deal and such
like a uh a Cornerstone of the of the
genre
um because it's just like it's not just
the linear hallway progression shooter
that you would expect out of Halo they
do a lot of cool stuff even like the
back tracking is different through how
they bring you through levels again the
Scarab fights that was always my
favorite yeah because the Scarab
fighting 2 was awesome but it was very
scripted yes but in three I remember
going off jumps on mongooses to land on
the scare and then hop off clear it out
throw some grenades at the end and then
jump out and
the one on
the ark the sand one where you're
fighting like this is it's like this big
battle where it culminates where you're
fighting it I remember I would like
because you you could like launch like
the warthog like into it yeah and like
land into and stuff I remember I would
do that and then like right before the
checkpoint would kick in I would like
reload it so I could just keep doing
that over and over again and try and do
it in like different ways I was like I
think I was just playing that one today
it is like the amount of variety within
a small contained section of level that
you get is so good and the Gunplay just
it's bungee gun play so it feels so good
interesting
um yeah anything else uh more one piece
um maybe watching One Piece what are you
up to now uh finished our Long Park yeah
all right that's a good that's a good
ending oh my God kicking through an
entire building let's go ridiculous it's
like so good and then like even the
story stuff that I wasn't expecting like
nami's whole thing yeah the the hand
pushing around the door I was like no
good it hits you right yeah it gets the
good action and the good feels what's
the next Arc now
um I've been trying so I've actually
skipped a lot because I've like got a
list with my filler and non-filler and
I'm in the whale right now
um oh okay I know yeah there's there's
so much nonsense in that show like it's
there's some bits where it's like yeah
just come on wait are you talking about
the Bible like what is it yeah right
exactly no I there's some it's like a
mechanic no it's a real whale but
there's a guy living inside the whale I
just got to it so I forget the names of
everything but yeah the uh
it's it's ridiculous and apparently it's
it's not filler it's part of the Canon
because I've been following up yeah yeah
I'm like all right whatever even some of
the main like Canon stuff I'm like is
this fella yeah but it's not it's just
them being like weird with it it's good
because it's the kind of idea that
someone would come up in a desperate
struggle to create fillers but it's just
like normal stuff for Oda I was like all
right I guess this is and it usually is
good but yeah it's fun to watch no
matter what but yeah there's some crazy
[ __ ] happening right now cool Jake
oh man oh I got my steam deck so I have
been playing a lot on the steam deck uh
uh I Revisited vampire survivors I
played it a long time ago but decided I
was gonna wait until I got my steam deck
before I really dug it oh yeah it's
great
um I tried it for five minutes and I was
like yeah whatever on Steam deck yeah
okay oh okay and I was like yeah this
game's fine I guess I don't know yeah I
mean like it can be like that but I I
think the more time you spend in it the
more like so that's that's what have you
played while pooping no no okay okay
Survivor experience
exactly but other than that I've been
playing temtem 1.0 uh which has been
interesting I am a big fan of the
Pokemon games despite that I understand
and agree with a good amount of the
criticism that gets sent their way so
temtem's been interesting because I feel
like it is a response to a lot of that
criticism
uh and I think some of it works it it
feels like a Pokemon game for adults
which is cool
uh it's a little
I don't want to say hard it's it's it's
a good difficulty uh I get a little
annoyed because just the random Tamers
you fight end up being more challenging
than I'd like them to be because it's
like you know it's like I just want to
get to the next gym battle or I just
want to get here and catch this Pokemon
but then I come across some random Tamer
who's like guess what all my temtem are
TV and IV trained or whatever they call
in this and then they just destroy me
even though like I'm a much higher level
than them
um but other than that it's really
interesting like I I really appreciate
it
um I think people who are tired of
Pokemon would really but but they still
like that formula but they're
disappointed with how the modern Pokemon
games have been we'll enjoy it because
there's definitely more challenge it
feels it still has like a youngish sort
of style to it but I feel like the some
of the some of the writing feels a
little maybe not stronger but a little
more geared towards an older audience
um that said it's not like dark or
anything do the temtems say [ __ ]
sometimes
that would be good imagine that Pokemon
just going [ __ ] I'm on fire but but yeah
I'm gonna leave
there's like a lot of neat quality of
life stuff that I wish Pokemon would do
there's also some weird things like I
I've played like seven hours and I
haven't found a fire temtem which
I I kind of like have you been through
like a volcano area yeah no I haven't
but I found water temtem before I had
anything to ride on the water it it
feels a little imbalanced in terms of
like what is available from the get-go
uh but then like the the other kind of
weird issue is like you know when I play
Pokemon I go kind of all in I IV Eevee
train I I breed I try to get the best
Pokemon I can and I enjoy that aspect of
the game but I would hate to have to do
that during the main story because
that's a lot of work uh I don't know
like you know for me when I play through
those games I have a team for the game
then I have a post game team that I put
together after and with this it feels
like it wants me to like build like a
really solid
good team that I've put a lot of thought
into for just the just for the story and
I haven't even seen like 90 of the
temtem so it's like but I don't even
know if I'm going to want to stick with
this one I might find something cooler
but
it's it's it's cool I kind of want to do
a video about her about like
it's Pokemon for adults more or less
like it what does that mean exactly like
for adults like you said the story about
all the Pokemon are naked yes yeah yeah
not safe for work Pokemon okay
um I I I think it because because people
get frustrated with Pokemon because it's
too easy it feels like it's for kids and
the thing is this Pokemon is for kids
right right like at the end of the day I
got into Pokemon as a kid if I was older
probably wouldn't care about Pokemon
when it come out uh and Pokemon
has continued to be kind of geared
towards kids sure there are some games
that have been harder
um some some are designed a little
differently some are more complicated
but I feel like as Pokemon has gone
older they've really kind of uh tried to
gear towards children and that makes
sense because that's where a lot of
their new fans are going to come from
and a lot of old fans like myself get
frustrated with that sort of design I'm
kind of past that with Pokemon I'm I
like what they're they're doing I love
the post game I'm mostly there for the
post game stuff but 1010 feels a little
more
nuanced it feels like I don't I wouldn't
recommend temtem to a kid because I
think they're going to get their ass
kicked and they're not going to be that
into it but I think people who have been
playing Pokemon for a long time and have
been wanting a challenge will enjoy
temtem
um there are some weird things like
there's a battle pass for this game and
there's weekly challenges and I don't
want to engage in any of that it's like
I have absolutely zero interest yeah but
then there's other cool things like all
the gym leaders you can fight again and
when you fight them again they use
competitive rule sets to make it even
harder
so a lot of interesting things
I yeah it's it it's cool it's cool I'm
happy I waited until 1.0 to what are you
planning on does it work on Steam deck
okay the other issue that I have is uh
it's always online so you see every
other person running around at the same
time as you so Quest objectives are just
surrounded with people you see them
behind them and if you disconnect
uh it just freezes like the game doesn't
freeze but everything just stops where
it is so playing on Steam deck runs well
until there's some little issue with the
internet wireless and then and then it
stops and there's no way to turn that
off it is always online and apparently
that's their Vision but playing it it's
like this doesn't need to for me doesn't
feel like it needs to be online because
like I I don't want to trade with random
trainers I want to battle random
trainers yet I just want to like
enjoy that world without a bunch of
people just running around with their
temtem that like are really end game
temtem so they're getting spoiled for me
like I'm seeing Evolutions to tempt him
that I don't want to see yeah okay so so
it's yeah like I If it was Pokemon I
think I'd be pretty annoyed especially
if it was like scarlet and violet and I
could see like
what the final evolution of some of the
starters are early on I'd be really
annoyed because I care about that I want
to keep that stuff a surprise at least
to the best of my ability with temtem I
don't care quite as much because the
designs I'm not super into but still it
kind of like gets rid of some of that
surprise I love when these things evolve
and you know it does the same thing
where you see white Silhouettes and like
yeah like the music plays and they
transform and it's like that would be
cooler except I already knew what it
looked like because every every Jackass
has been running around with that behind
them so have you tried coramon
no I have not tried that apparently
according to Jordan that could be cool
um it is also in a similar vein Pokemon
but aimed at more like
um players that have a little more
history with it and want to take it up a
notch so maybe that's that's the next
step for you I've I think I've heard of
it there was another one that I was
trying that I think was in your video
that you made about 10 like Pokemon
likes yeah yeah yeah that I tried for a
little bit and it seemed pretty good I
feel like a lot of the the Pokemon
I don't say imitation games because
they've they've done some really
creative things but I feel like a lot of
them lean too hard and like yeah we're
the hardcore Pokemon right right it's
like yeah you can make it harder but you
don't need to be like yeah this is this
is where this is where you know we're
gonna test you it's gonna be difficult
and you're gonna have to work for it and
it's like what's that weird Pokemon game
that's like Pokemon with guns that's it
looks like a joke but like they keep
making trailers for it saying like no
it's a real game like but it looks like
a joke Trailer World
uh maybe someone in chat said anyone
looking forward to powerworld
yes because it has this very
old but then it's
yeah I typed in Pokemon with guns and I
got a trailer for power world yeah yeah
that thing looks
wonderful weird it looks very cute like
and then yeah yeah exactly and you're
like yeah I'm curious how that will
actually turn out because it's right
again a real game and I'm like okay
you're taking the joke and you're making
it running with it you know it's and I'm
like uh it might be like like that like
Winnie the Pooh horror movie where it's
like yeah this should have been like a
two minute fan trailer you didn't need
to turn this into an actual movie
you know let's see wasn't there another
Pokemon like
um from a Korean development Studio oh
that's that one that was like it looks
beautiful yeah but that trailer gave me
uh yeah or something I have no idea
because it was like I started off
looking like a trailer for a Pokemon
like and then turned into like every
game possible yeah
we're talking about that game every
it's like it was from Korean
yeah it looks interesting if they do
actually everything that they're
promising that's gonna be it yeah that
looks like one of those uh we need to
learn the money games
I was like yeah we'll make definitely
making a game it's true yeah like
there's definitely some weird like
blockchain uh yeah I'm sure I'm sure
it's an actual real game and we'll come
out and stuff like it's just like the
incredibly suspicious in every way like
how are you making this this were weird
interesting
um yeah but that's Tim Tim anything else
the last thing uh I got to play Mega Man
Battle Network Collection at a event
last week two weeks ago it feels like
yesterday but also a long time ago uh
there's not a whole lot to say I mean
I'm a big fan of the Mega Man Battle
Network games that said I completely
forgot about that series until this
collection got announced and I got
pretty pumped because especially one two
and three those are all pretty good from
what I remember uh have you guys played
them at all yeah
I've hate them I like them a lot back in
the day
um I don't think I completed every
single one it was like I think I
completed one and two and yeah yeah
because they'd release one like
everything and they were big they're
like pretty long games as well they were
like 30 40 hours they released one six
months and they got to a point where
they were like we're gonna release two
at a time so they do like yeah they did
the Pokemon style thing from yeah in
this collection I think has both
versions of all the games I think three
onward they did two versions of of all
those games oh that's cool also I played
them yeah um
via emulation as well so I was like
keyboarding it like so I think not the
best experience does that mean like when
we get the collection like I can be like
all right I'll play Battle Network red
and you can play Battle Network blue I
think it's red Sun white moon
yeah there's not a whole lot it doesn't
make a whole lot of sense but um no
those I I definitely recommend checking
those out if you've never played them
they're not Mega Man game I mean they're
Mega Man games but they don't feel like
Mega Man games they are
they are RPGs with a card battling
system kind of
Persona e-vibes dare I say because you
go to school it's not you don't you
don't your schedule doesn't move like
persona but like the story takes you
through oh wow you go you go to school
basically the idea is that uh there's
the real world and then there's the net
and Mega Man is your character in the
net and in the net is where you do most
of your combat sleuthing uh but but it
switches between the two it's it's
pretty unique I feel like it's got to be
one of the first like card battle I was
gonna say how I feel like I haven't
heard enough about it but like every
indie game ever just sounds like what
you describe yeah and like no one talks
about these games I think that was the
most go ahead I was gonna say like it's
like the progenitor for a lot of like
even isekai stuff where it's like it's
it's a bit of that it's a bit of a card
Butler
um unlucky yeah it is it's pretty cool I
like them a lot yeah it it feels like
like because I I played him years ago
and I never really considered that it
was a card system but that's what it is
you have a deck of cards that you build
and basically when you use that card uh
or each turn you draw more cards and
then Mega Man can use those cards and
they are like special abilities but it's
real time so it's not like it's not like
you wait for that tap and you're still
moving around a grid you're shooting you
can shoot whenever you want
um but but
I never really considered it to be a
card battler until all these card
Battlers happened and then when I played
it I was like whoa it kind of did it
before all these other games oh yeah
it's really unique I I definitely
recommend giving it a shot the writing's
a little cheesy now well I've seen the
meme of there's like an old man and his
line of dialogue is I'm 30 years old
yeah yeah yeah yeah there's a lot of
like really weird good dialogues it's
pretty funny some of it's interesting
like they were explaining I think
they're like it's like a personal
electronic tablet or something it's
their little pet device where they can
connect to the internet and they're
explaining what this thing is like it's
some great piece of technology and it's
like oh that's that's an iPhone
it's kind of fun like it gives it a nice
uh Vibe like it is very much like
someone in the 2000s was like yeah this
is what the future is gonna be like
everything's gonna be online and people
are gonna have their little pet thing
we're all gonna fight with trading cards
or yeah whatever
I mean Mega Man seems to have predicted
the future pretty well here yeah I think
so it's neat though
um I'd give it a shot uh when that comes
out I don't know when it's coming out I
didn't do a very good job at doing some
research but it'll come out next year I
think cool probably that's nice anything
else
um that's it for me sorry okay cool John
Luke
uh I've been playing or played I beat it
uh return to Monkey Island
oh yeah how's that that's great uh I was
surprised how into it I got
um
I mean I have like a big love for uh
adventure games playing quick adventure
games and monk Allen specifically but I
think like
I've it's just been so long since I've
played that series that I was like oh
yeah
like that's cool but I wasn't like
admittedly super hyped for it
um more just like curious but like
playing it I was like it it 100 is like
it feels like a Monkey Island that like
hasn't skipped a beat as far as just
like capturing that Vibe and that energy
and that that like type of wit that um
like Ron uh Gilbert and uh David
Grossman are known for and like it was
just like immediately like all that came
flooding back I was like wow this is
super good uh uh yeah it's
it feels just like you know uh one of
those games again um but also making
some smart changes that make it more uh
of an accessible game for new people
um
by far the coolest thing it does is it
has this in-game approachable or
accessible
um sorry approachable not maybe not
accessible it's maybe not the right word
um I I wouldn't I I couldn't comment on
the specific accessibility yeah although
I know it has like controller options
yeah so
um I'm sure people can like make that
work but
um as far as being approachable it has a
in-game hint system well first off
actually when you start the game it
actually has a casual mode or a hardcore
mode I don't know if I agree with the
language for those but basically like
the Casual mode takes out some of the
puzzles and is kind of like if you're
here more for the dialogue and you don't
really care about puzzles
we won't include it hardcore mode is
just like classic adventure game like
you know it's gonna have all the puzzles
included it's gonna play like those old
games did but regardless of what mode
you pick you get this in-game hint book
that uh anytime you're stuck you can
pull up the hint book and the hint book
will know exactly what objectives you
are currently trying to do it also knows
how far you're in based on what items
you have and those who you've talked to
and so when you click on it it will give
you
a hint for like what to do next but it's
a it's just a Hint it doesn't outright
tell you so it'll be like oh hey
um you're trying to do this maybe you
should go talk to this person or like or
or it'll be like what person could maybe
know more about this kind of thing and
so it a lot of times I would just find
myself if I got stuck I would like click
on it and it would give me like just
enough of a vague hint at where to go
that I would like put it together in my
brain and be like oh I need to go talk
to that person and then like I would
immediately be able to solve it and then
if you are still stuck you can click on
it again you can be like no I'm still
stuck and it'll give you another hint
it'll be a little more specific and if
you click on it enough times it will
just outright tell you what to do
um but I think that is like such a cool
smart way to do it because it means that
like you never get stuck in the way that
you do with those old adventure games
where you're just frustrated you're like
I don't know what to do and also like I
don't think any of the puzzles are quite
as obtuse as like I mean you know
classic Monkey Island I think is known
for having some pretty obtuse Solutions
you know uh the uh rubber pulley with
the chicken is like a very famous one
where it's like how was I supposed to
know to do that yeah it's like that's
kind of the joke of that puzzle but also
it's like
yeah maybe don't make your puzzles that
crazy uh yeah that's what I was gonna
ask like are they as weird as they used
to be no for the most part I mean
there's still like there's lots of good
jokes surrounding them but none of them
are as none of them are weird in the
sense that like how was I supposed to
have thought of that like they all to me
like made logical sense and there was
only one that I actually got like stuck
on and it was
um basically like it was my fault where
I didn't realize
um you could there was like an item you
could pick up in a box and I didn't
realize that if you go back there that
item would refill and so you could
collect two of the same items so like
that that was the thing right like got
stuck there but I was like oh okay like
but
for the most part pretty obvious stuff
so uh I didn't have any trouble with any
of the puzzles I found it like very
Breezy
um to get through
it's super funny it's like you know it
is that Monkey Island humor
um a very like Charming little absurdist
um
appealing for all ages
um I think kids would like it the one
thing that is kind of weird about it is
that The Narrative of it is very
self-referential to Monkey Island like
it is a game about
returning to Monkey Island 30 years
later both like in the plot but also
like as the creators and they kind of
make fun of that like the whole thing is
guybrush is like I'm finally actually
going to discover the secret of Monkey
Island because the whole joke in the
first Monkey Island is that there is no
secret of Monkey Island you never learn
what it is
and so he's like I'm gonna find it out
I'm gonna find out the secret and a lot
of the humor is like other characters
pointing out like oh huh yeah you're
just uh coming back to to this well
again right you're trying to find the
secret and like kind of making fun of
the idea of players wanting to still
know the secret or like caring about it
I love that though yeah I love it too it
it's very much like poking fun at the
audience but in like a loving way of
like oh we're all here we all know what
we're doing you know is would you say
because I'm curious I've never played a
Monkey Island game I do like uh a
point-and-click adventure should I
should I check this out I I think you
should check it out even without
previous knowledge of it I think so I
think it doesn't enough of a good job
where it's like again you you know the
setup they explain what's happening
um all the characters are very well
explained like who they are and and you
know
it'll it'll just be a little weird when
it's like oh hey remember when I did
this or like you know they just kind of
like reference events in the past a lot
that I think some people will just not
quite be like oh like I you you'll
you'll have a lot of moments where
you'll be like oh that's clearly a
character or a joke that they're
referencing but you're not gonna maybe
find it as funny or
um as like oh nostalgic because you
didn't have that
um you didn't play those games but
I still think for the most part you
could probably like you would be able to
enjoy it and like appreciate it and it
has plenty of its own like original
jokes as well and new characters and
stuff
um good steam deck game for steam Decker
over here yes it plays great on the
steam deck it's the perfect steam deck
game
um yeah it's cool and it's like it it
references because it only it mostly
references one and two because those are
the games that um those two creators
worked on but it also does reference the
other games as well so like Marie the
talking skull who was introducing curse
of Monkey Island he's in this one they
reference The Telltale Game Tales From
Monkey Island which uh I have a fondness
for
um I think it's underrated and you
unfortunately can't even buy it anymore
because of all that Telltale stuff oh
weird can you ask anyone about Loom yes
okay you can ask the same guy about Loom
does it have the uh it is a Salesman as
well it is yes yes stands in it um the
loom joke's actually really funny
because you go you go up to the guy and
you're like hey uh can you can you tell
me about Loom and he's like
I'm so sick and tired of telling people
about me and I don't want to do it and
you're like come on man just do it and
he's like no and you're like why do you
have the button on and he's like
I can't take it off it's fused to my
body I'm more buttoned than man
that's amazing sounds it sounds cool I'm
gonna definitely check it out it's been
a while since I've played a Monkey
Island game
um I didn't play much of the the Tails
ones because I was done with it but
what's the art style how did the art
style come across to you because
obviously that's been a big point of
contention admittedly when I first saw
the trailer I also wasn't a huge fan of
the art style like something about it
just wasn't clicking with me I wasn't
like mad about it I was just like yeah
like Ah that's maybe not what I'm
looking for
I don't know what it is but like when I
started playing with it didn't care
about the art style at all totally found
it fine so like while I was playing it I
was like yeah this is fine it I think
it's got a very like
kind of storybook look to it the maybe
the one thing criticism you could Levy
is like it does make the characters feel
a little more like uh puppets kind of
the way they move and stuff like the way
they animate
um but I don't know I got over the art
style very quickly and and just was like
in it and and to be fair like also
it I I get that maybe it doesn't like
have the same like loving appeal as like
those classic
um you know like uh monk Island two like
the the scum you know like pixel kind of
art but uh it looks in my opinion a
thousand times better than the uh
remaster art style I went back and
replayed those and I think these look
ugly I actually don't like the way those
look at all in my opinion
um maybe that's a controversial uh take
but I actually don't like the way those
look and I think this looks better than
those so uh yeah our style looks good
funny it's Breezy eight hours and it's
super chill it's like yeah it's just uh
I don't know it's nice to get you know
get nice and cozy with a little
Adventure game have a good time nice
anything else
I finished Edge runners
I'm still only like five episodes in so
okay I won't spoil anything because is
it does it hold up I think so yes and
and in fact I was very happy with how it
ended I I found the ending to being very
satisfying
um I got a little emotional over it
um
it it uh ends a lot more satisfyingly
than the game in my opinion I did not
like the way the game ends
um I don't think any of those endings
worked uh but yes I found it to be very
satisfying and uh I was like uh damn I
would really like them to make another
one of these
um because I think Studio trigger just
had such a a brilliant understanding of
like what makes that world appealing and
like knew how to like capture it like it
to me like it it did its job in that it
kind of made me want to go back and
replay the game which I know a lot of
people have been doing because
apparently the game's like been jumping
in the numbers because of
and they have like some of the weapons
or they're like oh you can get like
Rebecca's shotgun yeah the music yeah
there's a couple tracks that they use in
the show that were in the game before
but now listening to them in the game
has a completely different context
I I finally watched the first episode
um and what I saw was really good I
liked it a lot I'm excited to watch more
unfortunately I am tied to Breaking Bad
right now I gotta finish finish that
because that's so hard to stop watching
that show well that's Netflix so you'll
get one more season before it gets
canceled so I don't think they're doing
another season I think they're just
doing it might just be the one and it it
it very much yeah I I am like
I I bet it comes back for another season
yeah although I will say if they do uh
they they should do it with different
characters yeah mostly because it it
ties in a way it wraps up in a way where
it's like this is the end of like they
could bring back some characters yeah
but like I would rather it be like all
right let's get like another set of
characters uh who are like you know
cyberpunks right doing their thing
that's the great thing about that world
is it feels like you could take you
could take anybody yeah yeah like like
uh whoever it feels like basically like
they took a uh a role-playing session of
cyberpunk and then just like made an
anime for it and I was like yes
absolutely that's sick um I think that's
kind of the most
one of the most successful things about
that game is that just that world is so
well realized and interesting and
exciting for me like I I'm I'm with you
a lot of the endings I didn't think were
very satisfying but man like I even last
night I just started up and drove around
a little bit like man this world is cool
and it seems like what they've done with
that anime is they've really leaned into
the World building that like you know
Mike pondsmith created CD projekt Red
breathe life and like more life into or
at least gave it like a
like like a concrete visual style yeah
right and then and and like I I don't
know I just think that world's so
fascinating and I really hope that
they Explore More cyberpunk sort of
visual
things I guess because obviously we've
got the cyberpunk 2077 DLC coming but it
kind of sounds like after that they
might slow down on the cyberpunk game of
The Witcher but I hope like I think they
did recently say that they have plans to
make a another game uh at some point
where they want to I thought I heard
that yeah I think I think they said in
some sort of way yeah well they said
they committed to cyberpunk as a
universe yeah they were like well we're
into this very very much I think we
canceled the multiplayer right they like
quietly we're like we're not doing that
but but here's the thing is because I'm
I'm with you where it's like as much as
I have my beef with like that story it's
also like well that story's done you can
make another story so I totally watch
equal to cyberpunk because I think
there's so much potential to it and some
people might not like this idea because
I think people are into the idea of
everything has to always be like new
when it's a sequel but to me it's like
keep the world keep like the map keep
night city as a map maybe add more to it
but keep all the hard work you already
did and just make a sequel that puts all
of your effort into like making the
missions as like amazing as possible
like it I would totally play a sequel
that is just like the same map but like
an all-new story with all new missions
and they just pour all their development
into that but suddenly that might be the
DLC like they're adding that new area
right but yeah yeah right but I'm saying
I would take even a full sequel for that
because I'm like you guys put so much
hard work into that environment and like
I would hate for them to be like well
we're we're just gonna build a whole new
game now yeah back onto the Witcher
go you know into the
I could it could just fall into the same
trap as the first one right I feel like
you try and like
build everything from scratch again so
yeah yeah it's the Yakuza approach right
like the most yeah
recycles the same city for like 20 years
and no one playing those games complains
they love it I mean maybe you get a
little tired of it but they had they had
another map I've been looking at
kamorocho for most of my life and I love
it yeah
I I am of the opinion that like as much
as like you could be you could make the
argument that like oh it gets a little
tiring I also think it creates a level
of familiarity with that City that no
other game
quite matches because normally in a game
you're like well we have to re do it all
like even like Mass Effect when like the
Citadel is in all three Mass Effect
games but it's always a different part
of the Citadel everything that always
kind of disappointed me every time
disappointed me too because they were
like well we have to make it different
each time if we just reuse the same
thing people will be upset and I'm like
well
I wouldn't because I I like the idea of
like you know keep building off of it
and just like expanding it so that's
what I like about the Yakuza games and
I'm one of those weird Gamers too who
like I think it was kiwami 2 lets you
like explore most of the buildings in
first person yes and you can just walk
like up to the roof and like look out
exactly over and I was just like this is
nice yeah that's what they do instead
they're just like well it's the same
street but now like more the buildings
you can walk into which is that so it's
so smart I think there's something so
powerful that you're describing where
it's we're just I we we play open world
games all the time but the amount of
time I just spend looking at the minimap
to get to where I need to go or
following the Waypoint and like I I want
to get to a point where I don't need
that you know where I can have enough
familiarity with a place where I can
navigate it through landmarks and a lot
of that does come down to level design
and
um and art direction right like totally
one thing
um like I remember about The Witcher 3
is that I found it pretty easy to
navigate because there were these pretty
noticeable landmarks throughout the
world so it's like okay I gotta go to
Nova grad that means I gotta head north
of the river and that would take me up
to novograd things like that but
um it's it's kind of like
it I I'm with you I just wish there were
less like rebooting these areas entirely
and just like okay let's revisit it
let's kind of build upon it let's get to
the point where I'm more familiar with
this area like yeah like you're saying
with cyberpunk would be a great example
because I was kind of starting to learn
that world and replaying it again last
night I was like okay I know this bridge
is going to take me here but like
I don't know that's just like a powerful
feeling to like walk into a game and
know exactly where to go without having
to follow a mini map exactly and they
can expand upon it by maybe like hey
we'll make these buildings more like
yeah you can actually go inside them if
it's more Interiors to do and yeah and
cool stuff like that that's the next
Frontier isn't it like insides of
buildings that's what I want oh my God
that's like this I'm gonna butcher this
but I think there's like a quote that
Warren Spector had where he was like the
idea of like the ultimate like immersive
Sim to him was like
uh just like one city street where
there's just so much detail in that City
street and you can do anything within it
and it's like that sounds that'd be so
really really cool to me yeah I think
that's why I mean that's why I love
Hitman those games it's just because you
could I don't know if you go into every
building depending on the map but like I
remember those suburb maps that suburb
map and blood money and they kind of did
a was it Hitman 2 where they added yeah
that too and it was just all these
buildings you could walk in and you
become very familiar with those streets
where people are gonna be how things are
gonna happen I think that's a little
different though because
it's more of a play like you kind of
know where people are gonna be at what
time but but like what you're describing
is sounds really cool that's you know
I'd love to see a game like that where
it's just a very small section that you
can
explore like a small section that's
really deep I guess yeah I mean that's a
lot of what arcane's games do as well
right yeah
that's true obviously Don Wallen kanaka
are a little bit bigger than most areas
that we're talking about here but like
they still have a lot of depth to them
and that yeah and like the whole death
Loop thing was like
small chunks but with a lot of depth and
definitely because of the nature of that
game because you're repeating things
over and over it also creates that same
sense of like you learn those maps in
and out and that familiarity yeah
smaller but deeper that's what we want
the Cosmic Fly says sapiens is a god
tier map so many apartments and offices
just to dick around them yes
kind of crazy that was they're one of
their first maps and it was just they
knocked it so far yeah yeah yeah all
their level designs great but man
safienzas yeah incredible
uh yeah anything else John Luke
uh that's the that's about it for me I
think yeah
um I've been playing a couple games
um that we can like quickly
go through
the game of the the week
based on the last two days trombone
champ oh yeah what a game has anyone
else played this no I I just saw it on
Twitter yeah it is as good as the
footage makes it out
am I the only one who like was were they
intentionally going for the like the Wii
music Vibe is that the joke that is
something really really like funny about
seeing like the Wii character the Wii
yeah like me character like trying to
play a trombone and it's like [ __ ] up
and it's eyes and I immediately thought
of like Miyamoto on stage I think like
like the gentle swing yeah
it is pretty much a like a a classic no
Highway rhythm game
um but it's like the energy it looks
when you look up a picture of it you're
like oh this looks like very doable but
because of the way the controls work and
the tuning of it so the controls are
with a mouse you like you can go up and
down but it's like
inverted to a degree so when you move
down it goes up and up it goes outside
the first thing I look for was an invert
and there might be one there but I
couldn't find it and then what you do is
like so you move that up and down to
line up your your kind of like cursor
with the no and then you click or press
a button on the note and then you like
try and follow the trail and move up and
down quickly to the next note
because of the way it works and the way
it's designed and the up and down motion
being like slightly reversed and it
being like a bit too sensitive it's
basically got massive quap energy okay
well you are always looking kind of dumb
you're slightly off and this is a game
where it wants you to try and hit the
notes
but it knows that its ultimate goal is
to make you fail and make it sound as
dumb as possible but like make it make
you do it just enough that you can tell
what the song is and you feel kind of
good at it but you also feel like really
awkward so the way I think of it is
you know when you listen to some music
and you're like singing along or you're
rapping along and you're like and then
the music goes off and you only hear
yourself
and you're like oh god oh no that's what
this is that's what this game is so much
so it's like you're playing it you're
like I'm getting it and then like you're
like well I'm very not getting it you're
like laughing and the game clearly knows
that it's it's that's how it works
because the amount of times I've been
like doing a note and it's awful it's
like and I look to the corner and it's
like excellent and I'm like what okay
yeah it's like great it's like good job
and it's like sometimes like I did one
it's like nasty and I'm like okay I
don't know what's going on
um but yeah the entire time like when
you're [ __ ] up a note like the the
me's eyes open in the way that knees
look shocked and it's just so funny and
they also do like dumb stuff with like
the songs are like almost like open not
open source for like royalty-free songs
like
um taking me to the base the ball game
or whatever like that kind of stuff so
it's like
all songs that you innately as humans
that have existed on Earth know how they
should sound right so that you have a
familiarity with it so when it [ __ ] up
you know I'm screwing this up but it
sounds kind of funny I do have a
freestyle they have a freestyle oh
interesting so when you're doing they do
this thing where like the like you do
Take Me Out to the Ball Game you're in a
baseball stadium and they have fun with
it we're like in the background there's
like old looking baseball cards and
stuff and every now and then like a ball
will come at the screen and hit you in
the face or whatever
um there's also the intro is a straight
up dog sales parody okay or it's like
you will stand between two like you know
uh not knowing your name Dark Souls 2
style was like you won't know who you
are you're just like a a nameless a
cursive or whatever but the whole thing
is like you will stand between in front
of two baboons and like they've got like
a whole baboon Motif going on because
there's an entry on the main menu which
is baboon and you click it and there's
like a weird occult ornate [ __ ] going on
and you can't access it yet and then
like you can see the silhouette of
baboons there for some reason and you're
like I don't understand what's going on
okay yeah amazing I'm so intrigued yeah
and then like on the loading screens
there's like
uh facts about the trombone and they're
all like dumb like it's like the average
trombone has five spiders living in it
um and then and then uh you can go into
the freestyle mode as you mentioned and
like try and
make your own songs basically play how
you want because it does like track the
notes pretty well okay um it's a really
fun game and
um surprisingly more fun than the gag
like you'd think oh you do this one and
you're done yeah that's kind of why I
didn't pick it up I saw stuff on Twitter
and I was like okay I get the joke and
then just kind of moved on but it sounds
like I should actually give this it's a
good time like it's a good time like it
it's one of those games where you can
probably come back to it for a laugh
every now and then like I played it a
bit yesterday before
um like jumping on a podcast to talk
about it and then I was like I want to
play a little bit more after and I had a
little fun
um it is like
is is for people that love fart jokes
and and like like a goofy time and it's
it's fun like it's one of those games
where you play on Steam deck as well so
it's one of those games where it's like
hey play this game hand it to someone
and like watch them and because if they
do well they enjoy it if they do poorly
great it's funny it's funny um so it's
like I thought 15 was a bit Steep and
then I paid it and I was like
is it worth it yeah it's a good time I
enjoyed it
um but yeah it's it was a lot of fun I
can recommend it as a goof and a gif
um beyond that I've been playing hyper
demon oh I can play a little bit of that
too Ty's uh a nightmare because it's an
absolutely I saw the game playing I was
like no it's not for me it's a sequel
spiritual successor to devil dagger yeah
which is like this is like it's like if
devil dagger was doomed this is like
Quake yes but I describe it as like
Quake if it was set in the world of Rez
which was also being sucked into a black
hole at the same time which is like I
was trying to think about the the main
menu
um like the effect on the text it almost
reminded me of like a Sega Saturn era
yeah
it also kind of reminded me like the
text is white but it reminded me of like
the Doom like yeah really like yeah it
looks like Times New Roman in red and
that's about it and like they like very
not minimum list but like
it has that edgy kind of like Indie
aesthetic 90s 90s kind of like a vibe to
it which is really interesting but also
like it's got a lot of gameplay depth I
think it's intro because it's like
it's it's unreal tournament basically to
a lot of degrees to the point where or
Quake if you prefer like the multiplayer
shooter style um of movement where you
strafe you feel like you're on roller
skates the entire time or you're like
just greased up to [ __ ] and you're
sliding around everywhere
um I think as far as I can tell the
levels all take place on a sphere like
you're always moving around like I can't
remember what is it Resogun like uh I
remember like early where you like
regardless of where you try it if you
keep pressing up you just go around this
thing like one of those puzzles yeah
Reserve gun had like an infinite Loop
yeah it's basically that
um and the movement is like that you've
got like a dash
um which you can basically do by tapping
A spacebar but you do it as the enemy is
about to strike you or like I think it's
like you jump and then if you press it
again you down so that's so if you jump
and you press it again you get like a a
kind of like forward slide yeah yeah and
then if you hold it you can jump out of
the slide or if you press it after the
slide you cancel the jump but the dash
is like a it's almost like a secular
moment where like you're moving enemies
will come they're like it's a big skull
usually of some sort and its eyes will
like brightly Shine for a second and if
you like do your dash at that point it
doesn't slow down it's got like weird
like Dash canceling yeah it's got that
it's also got like shoot at the ground
tap the like you if you have a rocket
rocket jumping okay so you can do that
twice and then you can like Glide a bit
as well
um and then the whole thing is like it
just sends [ __ ] tons of enemies at you
constantly and like they kill you pretty
much instantly so the goal is to kind of
like keep flying through these waves as
much as possible and survive for as long
as you can and and like it switches up
the types of enemies and then you could
like you're firing out of your hand It's
like got a hand on the screen the entire
time and there's gems about as well and
you can like suck in the energy from the
gems and like do like a railgun shot
from your hand yeah which will like
if you target properly will instantly
kill some enemies if you're hitting a
gem
um and there's like various other
power-ups as well
um it's all about surviving yeah is
there is it is the enemy placement
random or like generated because
whatever devil daggers was
it had like a scripted I believe it has
a kind of like so I was every time I
started playing it it would give me the
same enemies to start with so I think
there's like a progression to it right
okay yeah yeah so it'll introduce
different types of enemies at certain
points which makes sense because
like it's it's not easy to play one
right it's not easy to play because it's
confusing there's a lot going on but
also like the legibility of the game is
not great and I think that's by Design
like the amount of times I'm dead and
it's like because I don't know what
killed me because the screen is black
purple red warping skewing at the same
time and like I'm jumping in the air I'm
like I I don't know what killed me but
it's kind of like okay I'll try again
and like it's easy to jump back into it
so it's like extremely chaotic it's like
very very difficult to get to grips with
it's one of those games where I think
you can get as much joy out of just
watching someone who knows what they're
doing oh yeah because then you're like
how are you doing this but that looks
awesome and it's wild yeah um my
favorite thing about it is there is a
leaderboard and it does this really cool
thing where it's it's so like
it's one of those like real up yours
moments where
you you get a score and it will show you
climbing up the leaderboard in Rapid
succession as if you like it your name
will be there and it would like the
thing will be like a roulette where
you're going up but if you pass someone
on your friends list it slows down to do
like like a almost like a kind of like a
bullet time moment where you're going
past them so you get to read the names
like poor Danny or Dwight yesterday
I was like this is the first level I'm
sure he like jumped in played a bit and
left and then I was like playing for
like 20 minutes I saw his name Pop I was
like oh Danny and it slowed down I was
like boom I was like that looks [ __ ]
cool I like that I would be surprised if
loads more games don't do that like
that's such a cool neon white could have
used yeah yeah oh I agree that that
scoring system I thought was pretty cool
that leaderboard system was cool but I
feel like a little more Flair would have
yeah some some Flair to your leaderboard
yeah does it have
multiplayer because or like a
multiplayer component because when you
log in it tells you how many people are
currently playing the game yeah I think
it has a I think that's for like the
global leaderboard oh okay it's like
this is the amount of people you're
competing against right okay okay
because because when I saw that and it's
like these many people are online and
I'm like is this game got a hidden
multiplayer components that I'm not
aware of multiplayer that I'm just not
aware of I cannot fathom how you are all
these demons I'm shooting these actual
real people that's not about it like
imagine if you just suddenly all those
other skulls or like other players other
players
I don't think that's the case but yeah
that'd be cool yeah I just don't know
how a second player would even function
in that world you know it's a nightmare
hellscape constantly I'm just like okay
cool I've not tried it on Steam deck yet
though I don't know how you would do
like even on even with like I the only
way I survived for as long as I did was
like quick Mouse movements yeah you need
like a Pro Gamer High refresh rate set
up if yeah it looks like years of
playing on real tournament counts strike
that's kicked in I was like oh flicking
everything yeah but like I don't know
how you do that with like a a controller
situation or even like the the the kind
of like touch pads absolutely not
um but yeah I I recommend that game but
I would say watch a video before you
spend money on it because there's a very
good chance you'll be like this is not
for me I can't oh sure yeah
um it's what happened to me I think when
you were like we're gonna review it and
I looked at a video and I was like this
is not for me
um but yeah it's it's a lot of fun but
also it gave me a little bit of a
headache so I was like I gotta stop
playing this
um I don't know if I want to talk about
it but I forgot I also played the Modern
Warfare 2 Beta oh yeah I don't know you
played a little bit yeah I don't know if
that's something we want to touch on how
is it thank you Richard thank you
Richard Lee who's switching for us
um
it is so
it's it it feels like a sequel to Modern
Warfare and that uh Aaron talks about on
the team Aaron talks about this a lot
but there's kind of two camps of Call of
Duty games there's the there's the one
that lead more towards Mill Sim there's
one that lead more to little rkd yeah
this is Modern Warfare leaning more
towards the milsim side if you're into
that you'll probably enjoy the
multiplayer of Call of Duty uh Modern
Warfare 2 if you're more into the
arcades side this may not be the Call of
Duty for you I will say uh of all the
things they showed off that's coming to
Modern Warfare 6v6 multiplayer is the
least interesting to me at this point
just because
you know I've played the the milsim
style I played the arcade style I've
been playing Call of Duty since two so
it's like I know it's another sixth
domination like I fired the guns and I
was like okay these guns feel really
Hefty and grounded and there's a lot of
kick to them I I personally like that so
it's like this feels good but then it's
like okay now go capture the objectives
you know that Mojo and playing for years
I was like okay cool so so I think it
feels pretty good
um
but
it's it's hard to say I want I want to
see the the more interesting stuff I
want to see ground war I want to
Invasion which I guess is now in the
right beta currently which I haven't had
a chance to play Warzone 2.0
yeah yeah
um I'm super curious to see how they
handle that um tarkov style gameplay and
a Call of Duty game
um
yeah I mean I I don't know you you
played some too like yeah how are your
thoughts I think you're a little more
lukewarm on Modern Warfare one than I
was
um I actually like the multiplayer I did
get into it for a little bit
um and then I tried I didn't like Black
Ops or I played like one match of
Vanguard I played like two matches
like I haven't played Savannah I'm like
sure and I play like one or two matches
and I was like I don't like this I just
didn't like the maps or anything so yeah
I like I like this it yeah like guns
feel good I I kind of like the I think I
think they this is a weird thing to be
into but like there's something about
the way
they
uh your character moves in the
animations that I think is like really
satisfying like when you sound too like
Yeah The Sound mixed with the movements
when when you do like a uh when you're
sprinting and you crouch you'll do like
a dive prone where you'll like jump and
then just like laying on the ground
to it that I'm just like oh that was
satisfying or like there's this one uh a
gun I don't know I guess it only works
with this one gun
um which is kind of weird it can do with
others but where I had um a pistol as my
secondary and when I switched to the
pistol my character would like hold the
assault rifle like in their left hand
and then pull up the pistol and do this
like special animation and then when
they reloaded it they would put away the
gun reload it and then they went to
holding the pistol with two hands and it
doesn't actually change anything from a
gameplay standpoint I just thought that
was like a cool little touch it's like a
nice floor yeah it's like a little
flourish a little animation flourish
that I was like that's neat I like
stuff like that like that yeah you know
in a world where like it's a shooter
it's gonna shoot the same for the most
part like little animation flourishes
like that kind of like make it for me um
or at least like maybe a little more
invested and interested I think that's
what got me into 2019 Modern Warfare
um because you know I've like I said
I've played every Call of Duty I was
interested in Modern Warfare but I ended
up playing it for like hundreds of hours
I played a lot of that Modern Warfare
2019 multiplayer but like you're right
even with that game it was those little
details like reloading the shotgun just
looked like it looked yeah
like it looked like a person was
reloading the shotgun which sounds dumb
to say it's not like a video game
character like
yeah they're doing that like but it
looks like someone's stressed and like
in a battle Yeah Yeah and the it those
touches I really like and it's something
that I feel like Infinity word has kind
of carved out for themselves in terms of
the Call of Duty yes
um series I guess because you know you
got all these sub series now but uh but
yeah I mean it's more Call of Duty I
think like if at this point you're very
over Call of Duty this probably isn't
gonna do it I mean maybe DMZ could be
something but we're not gonna be able to
check that out for a very long time
because well not that long but when you
think about it like multiplayer comes
out or single player comes out end of
October and then multiplayer comes out a
week later and then that comes out in
November and I'm pretty sure that's free
because it's war zone yeah 2.0
technically so I don't know I mean it's
a known quantity but it's a known
quantity that I
enjoy and I'm excited for having us more
so than like you with cold war and
Vanguard totally and I definitely want
to check it out this weekend on PC
um because I I found myself gravitating
I normally play Call of Duty on Console
but I actually played a lot more Modern
Warfare 2019 on PC
and I like the way that felt so I kind
of want to try that here I will say real
quick I think the menus in that game are
the UI is cards
where it's like these J it's like I
don't panels yeah
yeah
but it's like oh like it's just like I
don't know where anything is and then
like some of the panels will just be
like buy our cosmetics and they're like
what the [ __ ] and then uh the weird
progression system with trying to unlock
guns so
um I was like looking at the gun uh the
all the gun options and I was like okay
I'd like to unlock an SMG and when you
and maybe I don't understand this maybe
I'm just wrong here and I'm stupid but
it just shows that they're locked and I
go okay
how do I unlock them normally it'll say
like level 24. don't watch it it doesn't
say that on the menu
but some of them didn't so I would just
do some though it would just say locked
and I was like what do I do and I was
talking to David about it and he's like
oh so uh when you go into a certain gun
and you go into the gunsmith there is
like a progression tree that will unlock
attachments for that gun which is like
normal Call of Duty right you use the
gun and you unlock attachments but it'll
also unlock other guns with some of
those so you have to like go into each
gun and check the progression to see
which gun unlocks from that rather than
just it telling you hey you should go
use this gun if you want to unlock this
gun and I I like genuinely was like I
have no idea how to unlock this SMG I
want to use I do not know how to do it
absolutely infuriating I do not
understand why someone thought that was
a good idea it was weird too because I
feel like those of us who played in the
office were pretty unanimous that this
UI sucks but David did that video where
he said the UI wasn't great and we a lot
of the comments were like are you
kidding me like it makes a lot of sense
and I was like are we playing the same
game here's the thing I think it's
because they've had that bad UI for like
four Call of Duties and all those people
are just using they're used to it yeah
and also like it's it's
it's designed for this is going to sound
real bad for Call of Duty brain like
yeah Call of Duty brain is its own thing
at this point it is like things that
make no sense to like
most Gamers people who like games almost
normal people make perfect sense where
it's like oh this thing you need to look
at this thing here to unlock that thing
over there like to them they're like of
course there's a flow to it because this
gun leads to this like I just want to
use the SMG how do I use the SMG what
you're saying is exactly true because
the comments were like actually makes a
lot of sense because that light machine
gun also uses five five five six exactly
also uses so that's where I'm like okay
like I kind of know that stuff because
like I've played enough Shooters but
that that doesn't make it good UI no no
it's like weird gun porn stuff yeah
military expert
um there are some there are some things
I do like like I do like how you
swapping receivers kind of changes the
gun feel and stuff sure and like how
those attachments kind of carry over
from there but I feel like the receiver
is the thing that's confusing a lot of
people yes how that works because
you can access the guns or you can pick
your M4 and then swap the receiver and
turn it into that SMG or that uh that
ccg that lmg
exactly exactly like that's the thing
it's like the the level of customization
that they have is neat the way it's
presented is so bad and confusing and
you're like I don't understand I
remember when it's gonna make me sound
old as [ __ ] but like I remember when it
just be like oh you want the gun go to
level three yeah yeah
my guitar riff plays and then and then
you'd unlock the gun and be like now
pick your one attachment 15 years and
now it's like you get
you get it's like here's the
his and then like like okay I'll take an
attachment they're gonna go
oh [ __ ] I'm like why are you doing this
man just let me just I do feel like that
stuff is like designed for people who
are like yeah either like really like
into gun porn or like it's made for
YouTubers so they can make like their
like weird build videos of like the
ultimate Call of Duty like you gotta put
this attachment in this and this because
it's like that's what I would do like I
look at that and I don't at least for me
and this is just like fine I'm as a
casual like I would rather it also give
me like a recommended Loadout because I
don't want to sit there and like go
through like the 20 different
attachments on the gun and be like I
have no idea like I would just go look
up a video of like a Call of Duty like
YouTuber who would be like put this gun
on this and this and that and you're
good right you know yeah it's just I
don't know I think I might be reaching
like the point where I have to just
admit to myself maybe this maybe
multiplayer isn't for me anymore yeah um
yeah I was out of war zone or like yeah
I mean yeah I'm going back to like the
modes I am excited for like spec ops I'm
curious to see what they do with that
because speca ups for Modern Warfare was
kinda disappointing because it was
they were like really prolonged
difficult multiplayer missions and like
the thing about spec ops before was it
was just like hey your guys in an AC-130
and you're on the ground and you need to
clear this burger joint and then that's
like it and it was like a minute long
Mission and it was a lot of fun but then
yeah but then like modern warfare was
like what if we just make giant maps
that that you have to drive around to
get to different objectives and enemies
are spawning and all of a sudden eight
juggernauts attack you and they all and
it's like it's a little too much I just
just want it simple so I'm curious to
see what happens with spec ops I think I
think that could be interesting not
something I'd return to frequently but
um something I'm curious to check out
for sure yeah so yeah it's the paint is
open now so right and anyone can check
out no so the beta was closed for
PlayStation last week and then it opened
for the weekend and now it's closed for
everything else but it opens Saturday
Sunday four okay cool everything else
got it everything else and it's open
open so you can just like it's open open
see it doesn't matter what you have it
on okay
yeah right now if you want to play PC
you have to pre-order it obviously I
think I could be wrong but it's the same
way because I didn't have a code I had
that yeah or if you're an Xfinity
customer then they sent you a code which
was like why the one time my dad has
ever been like go play this video game
was he sent me an email and was like
maybe you could use this
so I actually went to that Xfinity thing
that's the first time I've ever used the
Xfinity like reward system the rest of
the rewards Are all uh like sweepstakes
like entries and it's like for being a
valuable customer you can enter to
potentially win a dinner with Gordon
Ramsay and you're like I'm not gonna win
any of this this is a [ __ ] too you know
with Gordon Ramsay I bet you he hates
everything I want to eat
you're like oh you want to get some uh
in and out or something in and out you
donkey take them to Taco Bell oh my God
from everything I've heard and seen
Gordon Ramsay actually is very chill yes
and he's like he loves it like some junk
food and every now yeah I want to watch
him yeah yeah he's really good it was
surprised I feel like if you had like
what's his name Jamie whatever his name
is Jimmy Oliver Oliver that's where
you'd be like oh I don't like it yeah an
actual snob yeah yeah
um whereas like Gordon will be well out
for like just a a kebab at the end yeah
yeah okay
um yeah uh yeah so that's Modern Warfare
beta oh sorry one more thing Kirby's
Dream Buffet is awesome is it good yes
also one that was like 15 bucks yeah
really and then I was like this is what
I will play instead of Fall Guys pretty
much sorry that's the end of what I've
been playing with it I had to shout that
out um let's go on to the question of
the week brought To Us by Maria AKA
serious business in the games for
Discord if you want to get into games
while Discord hit me up or Lucy up and
we'll do a quick background check and
then let you in uh and uh you can also
respond to this and many other questions
of the week opposed by Maria this one
was has a game ever inspired you to pick
up a new hobby maybe Tomb Raider
inspired you to pick up archery or
Persona if I've got you into coffee
brewing this this question isn't the one
that's pinned but I don't think we've
answered this one this one yeah this was
last week's questions I thought I
changed it but I must have maybe let's
do this one real quick
um we can do both so
this is like a failed attempt but um I
for a while really wanted to uh my
motivation to learn Japanese was because
I really wanted to play Asian
um because it was you know we're gonna
come out and now I don't have to so I'm
like time to throw these Japanese
textbooks out the window I don't need
them
um I still would like to learn but yeah
it like nothing about the game itself
but like in the game but like yeah I
kind of wanted to learn Japanese to play
that game yeah but I still do want to
learn Japanese because I think I that
would be one a rewarding experience but
also like could open up the world of
interesting Japanese games to play and
hey I can watch anime without uh without
subtitles look at that oh and then I
could watch anime while doing other
stuff finally oh and then my
productivity will increase that's the
dream that's the dream I can do that a
little bit Yeah but every now and then
I'm like what do you say yeah because
that's the thing is like I can watch any
other show I can have it on the
background while I'm doing like a
billion other things I can't do it with
anime I'm like oh yeah
yeah I uh I picked up the Bushido code
after playing ghost of tsushima
um as in the book The Bushido code yeah
well I thought you just suddenly changed
your life to live
by the Bushido code no I picked it up
just because I was interested it's not
really a hobby but it was definitely the
similar thing of just like I was so
enthralled by that game and it was like
oh I want more I want to learn more and
like do all that so I I yeah picked up
the and they're like tiny too they're
like pocket-sized so I was like carrying
around I looked like such a
it's doing a boss with someone's like
pulls out a thing like he's like Bushido
code put on your glasses yeah exactly
it's reading the Bushido code and then
some some other fellow across the bus
who also has a Bushido code is like
see you I got you yeah that was that was
the most recent one I can remember
so your hobby is the Bushido code yeah
yeah yeah exactly trying to be the same
way
uh I don't know if this is necessarily a
hobby but uh after playing control I got
into like brutalist architecture and
like looking that kind of stuff oh yeah
and then I read House of leaves too
which is
um very similar to control which I
highly recommend if you like horror
novels it is terrifying
um in terms of hobby though like
I don't know like climbing is one thing
that I did quite a bit of for a while
but I wouldn't say that was directly
influenced from a game but I'd be lying
if I said I wasn't climbing and we're
like yeah I just got to look for the
yellow hand holds yeah you know oh yeah
uh I played uh death's running and took
up walking
okay yeah
if you stop by and then you walk I'll be
four miles they'll be there in an hour
I walk everywhere with like I am
literally like I'm gonna walk this city
as much as I can it's because I'm like
come on there are some hills on that
journey to your place as well like I've
been going back and forth between my
apartment and Lucy's apartment recently
um oh boy there's some hills that I'm
like this is just vertical like what the
[ __ ] and like you can see like I'm
struggling up this hill where I have to
like physically pop my leg down and then
push myself up to the next top and I'm
like you know it's bad when they switch
the ramp to stairs
I think Fillmore does that yeah so I do
like walking but I always I've always
loved walking
um but yeah I don't think anything hobby
wise that I could think of like I've
talked about how like anime has done
that a lot like I watched Hajime and
Oppo and then took out boxing
um which was an interesting one but I
don't think there's a
I started watching uh uh what is it uh
yeah
yes and I'll admit it made me want to go
bake something yeah
bread now how how far into it are you
I'm like
five episodes how good is that it's so
so good well one it it has this like
that like 2000s era anime vibe that like
I didn't know I wanted right now like
it's very nostalgic so wholesome and the
intro is like just the most like anime
ass anime intro where it's like oh it's
like them like wistfully looking on the
top of a hill over the cities and
there's a fight happening there's a
fight happening and he's flying at one
point but like the whole thing is like
they're just making bread so the anime
is about the kid yeah it's about a kid
named azumakazuma and he likes which is
a great basic great name
um and he's got his special he's got a
special ability he's got solar hands
which means his hands are warmer than
most normal people but that means that
when he's kneading dough it ferments it
faster
and his whole thing is he believes that
uh Japan's national dish shouldn't be
rice it should be a form of bread like a
lot of other so his whole goal is to
convince Japanese people that bread is
actually really good
um and like he keeps coming up with
these new bread ideas and uh he wants to
he wants to be a like a master Baker
yeah and and he gets and the whole thing
is like it follows the Shonen Arc where
it's like there's a tournament Arc where
he's like yeah yeah like the start was
like the like entrance exam Arc where he
has to like get into like this Bakery
yeah and the whole thing is like it's a
comedy anime and it's all built on like
puns like so it's like the comedy is all
about puns so and there's another
character named kurianagi who's a like a
well-known uh Baker and also like he's
like the the Prue or or or the The
Examiner basically
um voiced by the same person not voices
Dio in in uh in JoJo which is why you
probably recognize that yes also I've
been watching um uncle From Another
World which is also voiced by that guy
he's every Uncle so like I'm watching
free anime with that guy so in it what
happens is like he will come in and he
will basically taste the bread and what
I have what eventually happens is he
will have like physical reactions so
like and they will use that to like
explore how the bread makes him feel so
there's one which I won't spell I don't
know if you've restarted it but like
actually so let's put this one
um so there's one that's not as funny
like where instead it's like a melon
bread and he eats it he doesn't know
much about the bread and he'll eat it
and then what happens is like he
contorts physically to become a lemon
yeah and it's like really dumb and
eventually it goes to the point where
they start doing parodies of other anime
oh my God and like it's it's really it's
really good it's really my current
favorite joke is that he um just keeps
accidentally making other cultures
breads without realizing it so he like
he's like I've unveiled my like this new
creation of bread is like I call it so
the the punish also he calls his breads
Japan because pan in me is bread yeah
and like he wants to make bread for
Japan and you're like I've I've created
Japan number 78 and it's just a baguette
and they're like that's a French
baguette man yeah yeah there's one where
he makes this like weird like volcano
shape that's my favorite one that's
where it's like a bowl and he's like oh
it's perfect for curry and they're like
you just made no Indian bread that's
what that is the way he does it is like
he he like heats the oven and then he
gets the like the bread and then he gets
like a dough a circular dough and he
puts it on the top and they're like what
the hell is he doing and then he goes to
the oven and sticks it to the top and
then like which is genius
over time it like starts to droop so
then when time it's done it's a volcano
it's a volcano and then he like turns it
around and puts the curry in the bottom
so it's like the lava from the volcano
and you're like I'm gonna try that yeah
by the way that is actually how
traditional naan bread is made
oven in my backyard when I lived in
Pakistan that's exactly how you do that
they don't do the weird droops on like a
thing like a cloth that has like a
material circular material inside and
you like stick it to the side it's
incredible and we used to make massive
ones so he's trying to make a big one so
my there was like a time one so big that
like we we had to like throw it over our
shoulder oh my God and like yeah and
like pull it over I found a YouTube
video of someone who's like you can you
can actually make like a solid
approximation using like a cast iron
like and flip it over on your stove to
make like but like this yeah you can and
but there's nothing like Anonymous no I
know but I'm like they're so hard to get
those ovens yeah I'm like I can't I
don't think my uh landlord will let me
put one of those in my apartment so
maybe I'll just have to use the cast
iron for now yeah I will but that anime
gifts like it it's it's really good for
a really long time there is a point
where it starts to become a bit not as
good because it starts introducing like
a classic it becomes like a bit modern
anime if you know what I mean I think
it's around the time that like food Wars
started to show up and yeah because
right now it kind of has almost that
like it's of that era where it's like
like Yu-Gi-Oh kind of like it's like
it's like that Arrow or like like
original one piece also like there's uh
he's like Mentor is uh I forgot his name
but he's a fist he's like a Fist of the
North Star character oh yes he's like
he's the guy he yes I I know yeah he's
basically kentro yeah but as a as a guy
who's um like also teaching but he's got
an afro anyways because he feeds uh the
horse's bread yeah yeah yeah but there's
like they they really lean into the
control part of it where he just does
um
like he's like super super ripped I want
them to bring in the Baker from uh
Kiki's Delivery Service his name is Ken
matsuhiro
oh my God
sorry to go horribly off tangent but
actually I thought of one I did in
middle school take a parkour because of
Assassin's Creed there you go there you
go hey Bales uh no but I did jump into a
pile of leaves okay so that was mine I
hope you had like the like Assassin's
Creed like soundtrack playing while
you're like screamed Like an Eagle as I
did it as well yes I just remembered it
I just remember there's an episode with
uh Japan witch
Detective Conan shows up for some reason
that's amazing and he's like what am I
doing here I'm like it's so good yeah
I've been just like watching that like
in the bed just like put it on like just
casual like anime yeah another known fan
of that
um series air games but is Chris Pereira
because I introduced oh of course
yes and just do it
um you should watch it as well it's like
great as an anime to have like alongside
your main anime yeah that's exactly it's
like while I'm doing one piece I need a
break I can go yeah
um let's move over to the other question
of the week by Maria
um if you could own a vehicle from a
video game and be able to operate a IRL
what vehicle would you choose I would
100 choose D Walker from metal gear
solid five yeah
it's like very portable and you could
get around everywhere and like I could
walk that into my apartment and I don't
have to pay for parking all those Hills
would be nice all those Hills would be
nothing and like I could like get off
that thing and walk it to my desk and
just put it next to me now is if remind
me D Walker is the actual like it's the
little metal gear unit that you're
standing oh no that's death stranding
yeah yeah yeah yeah decorating kind of
has it has it's basically it's called
yeah yeah they've got those Auto ones
that you can load up with carts and
they're just legs oh I love those yeah
can I can I just say Metal Gear Ray can
I just like have a metal gear oh man if
you want yeah
very very limited using capacity though
yeah that's my favorite Metal Gear Ray
rules
I'm trying to think of something else
that would be
um
yeah because I'm like yeah vehicles are
like a remarkably like ordinary yeah
like I wouldn't actually want like a
Halo warthog like what am I gonna do
with this like that thing controls like
a nightmare so let's figure on ice all
the time yeah slipping around like this
oh no no I was probably just gonna swing
and hit you none of the Halo Vehicles
work in real world like I got one which
is it if if it was possible Bowser's
helicopter oh his little thing
I feel like Dr Eggman probably has some
good vehicles yeah he's kind of got the
same thing Bowser Jr Bowser yeah do do
Pokemon count because like uh Lapras is
technically a vehicle
oh yeah ever because the anime they
would like ride Lapras around during the
orange Islands Arc and I was like I
wanted that so bad I'd be like that'd be
so cool
I was gonna say like the Batmobile from
Arkham Knight that'd be kind of cool yes
really hard to control again yeah yeah
you couldn't fit in most streets you'd
just be running over oh I want the Mako
I want the Mass Effect one maker driving
that with the Hop through San Francisco
you're just in traffic also
[Music]
I mean like given the way the uh Tesla
is going that might be how the [ __ ]
that thing that they're making performs
because it looks like the Mako so it
probably will perform like the makeup as
well speaking of uh Tesla cyberpunk has
some really good vehicles yeah yeah
which they're they're Akira bike is sick
yeah the bikes are cool but they're
still motorcycles tonight yeah kill
myself
maybe one of the airships from like
Final Fantasy it's got like so many yeah
ships but one of them's gotta be good
can you have a choke about can that
count signs are form they are primarily
like bread for like my travels so I
wouldn't play the music though oh you
know what no I want the I want noxus's
car from Final Fantasy 15 because it can
turn into a point a plane would fly
doesn't it break down all the [ __ ]
time though yeah but you know me my boys
I just I just love the idea of like
again like in San Francisco like driving
and then being like ah the traffic and
just like on the paper is just like this
oh my God anytime Ben pulls that out in
Final Fantasy 14 It's the funniest thing
because like I'll be like hey Ben I need
to play with you and he's like oh I got
you and then he just pulls out like the
car and I just hop into it and his
character is like massive massive and my
character is like one of the tiny cat
girls so it looks like a little child is
just like in the front like the
passenger seat next to this huge fan
who's like taking me for a ride and I'm
like oh I feel like that's the most
anime ever yes just that feels very
anime I love it well there you go
asked and answered and that brings us to
the end of another episode of the games
for after dark podcast if you would like
to send us questions you can do that in
the Discord again hit me up if you want
entry or help Lucy if you're on email
questions you can go to after dark
podcast at gamestop.com
um John Luke where you at what are you
up to ah you can find me at johnkey on
Twitter and I am up to no good no good
I'm watching I'm baking bread
um I got
some stuff I'm working on that I can't
talk about for a little while actually
but it will in the future exciting
things will be happening
Stu I'm on Twitter at Stewie reviewey
and what am I working on right now oh uh
10 things you didn't know about Halo
that's been my you know junket for the
past couple weeks nice I am at to more H
pretty much everywhere
um I am working on nothing
I don't do nothing
yeah I don't know what I'm doing it's
all kind of a blur I guess uh on Sunday
we're gonna have a wild west expert
reacts to Red Dead Redemption 2. I cut
that it's looking pretty good looking
pretty interesting uh up the deal field
Chronicle review just went up uh Stu did
the voiceover for that I edited that
um Wild Goose what's his full name yeah
David uh reviewed it
um
I played that game too but I didn't
really want to talk about it that's
probably for the best yeah I I thought
about putting it in there and I was like
yeah I think we're okay uh and then I'll
probably be doing run a lot of support
for Call of Duty stuff because uh that
beta is happening and we got a couple
people in the office who are very
excited for it yeah uh
and I'm supporting the excitement I
guess
the best way to put it yeah there you
have it thank you for watching again if
you haven't already please do follow on
Twitch if you're listening on podcast
services please do subscribe and rate
and review if you can it helps us
massively tell your friends tell your
friends about us you know yeah we're
also we're live at 3 P.M on Thursdays
yeah I guess we're specific we don't say
that a lot on the episode but if you're
listening to this and you're like I kind
of want to check this out on Twitch
twitch.tv Gamespot three to four
thirty-ish yeah Pacific time yeah yes uh
we'll see you on the next one bye
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]